it's because the people
you know people who experience sudden
wealth events don't know how to deal
with it
either financially emotionally
psychologically we talked about having
the target on your back
it can be an extremely soul-crushing
uh and traumatizing experience we all
say oh boo-hoo
these millionaires or whatever but you
know until you walk a mile in another
person's shoes it's tough to
it's tough to be empathetic and i'll
tell you i know i know more than one guy
a more than one professional athlete
some of whom said it on camera some of
whom said it off camera
that they love being bankrupt
they said the phone doesn't ring anymore
i can relax i'm not paying all these
bills that i don't even know who they're
for or what they're for
you know like you know once people think
you're broke or you file for bankruptcy
which you know doesn't necessarily mean
you're broke but you have you know
you're looking for bankruptcy protection
uh because of your debts like they just
think i know one
uh professional football player who's
like who took his last like
10 million dollars or something and made
like a kamikaze investment
like they made the least liquid
investment they could possibly
make pardon me they didn't lose the
money but they put it someplace where
they basically knew
it's going to be inaccessible for like
20 years maybe you know
you know and like they did it on purpose
they did it so that their family and
their friends and
you know and unscrupulous business
people would stop
praying on them and so they could have a
moment's peace so
it's you know it's again none of us have
had that kind of money so we don't
understand what it's like to have to
deal with that
but it's it it's you know people who
come from nothing
and suddenly have it all it's a it's a
real shock
uh to it can be a real shock uh to the
system and there is no
little to no training yeah the the end
the the players associations and unions
have some classes or whatever
the um you know agents can be helpful
some of them aren't so helpful um
colleges don't seem to give a [ __ ]
even though they know that like a subset
and it's a small subset
but you know tiny percentage of this
population of student athletes
are going to go on to you know
experience great wealth and success and
they don't really effectively
while they're exploiting their unpaid
labor
they don't really effectively prepare
them for a future
of of of financial large s and so um
that's that
and if you want to get into the anthem
thing we could get into the anthem thing
yeah but i don't know which which can't
work sorry
there's so there's so many there's so
many cans flopping around
janking around in my head right now i
don't even know what but like
i feel like it's always weird thinking
i'm sure that this is something that you
understand
pretty well with dealing with you know
doing all these
pieces on athletes and stuff like that
but when you acquire that much money and
fame
at such a young age it's harder to
process real-life
drama or or relationships or friendships
because you don't have real life
experience you just have
the experience of being a celebrity
living in your own bubble everyone's
saying yes to you
um you get this i call it superman
syndrome like you get it
when you you grow up and people are
telling you how great you are and how
good you are at something and you
achieve
you know some modicum of of or some
significant fame
uh and financial success it definitely
[ __ ] with your head um
and and actually and especially for for
wrestlers who live in such a
an action figure world where they are
literally action figures
and then they spend the rest of their
lives trying to continue to look like
their action figure
you know physically and aesthetically
and everything it's hard when you're
kind of out of the spotlight and that's
a lot of randy's story when he gets kind
of
pushed out of the ring at wwe
um and winds up you know going across
town so to speak working for the
competition
um that was that was hard for him you
know go
you know buying up all the just for men
at walgreens to keep his hair and his
you know his beard well there was no
hair
but to keep his beard dark and and just
like
it's a really interesting struggle that
that athletes and
especially sports entertainment because
like it's it's
so much about the aesthetics and the
look you know and maintaining that
physique and everything
uh it's hard i think psychologically to
be kind of to feel like you're being put
out to pastor that your action figure is
being
dumped in the trash can so to speak it's
you know and it's hard
i call that spotlight syndrome because
you go from superman to being out of the
spotlight
and you don't know how to process all
you know we made a documentary 30 for 30
called broke
about in part that phenomenon that like
when you
when your professional sports career is
over which for most
athletes is in their 20s maybe if
they're lucky they're 30s or if you're a
baseball player in your 40s maybe
um but like i mean in the nfl the
average career is like
3.3 years and they have the lowest
uh average salaries um they have the
highest rate of career-ending injuries
uh and when you're out suddenly maybe
you're at home with a wife and kids you
don't really know
that well or how well you get along with
them um you don't have the team doctor
to take care of you anymore you may
start self-medicating
you know with prescription or
recreational drugs and you don't have
that health coverage you don't have that
access to those uh those resources
anymore and you are not bringing in
you are not generating the revenue you
were generating
just a short time ago and you will never
generate odds are that
amount of revenue ever again uh in your
life it's it's a tough
it's a tough uh uh uh axe to uh
to bear randy was notoriously thrifty
though
uh which he apparently learned from his
his father who was known professionally
as the miser
uh in england oh you mean like gambling
he was a gambler like he was a car shark
he like had the first dollar he ever
made like
cheap cheap cheap uh people used to make
fun of him
um and so i think he was
randy was kind of smart with his money
not so much because he was
because the secret to being successful i
think or generating money
is you don't spend the money while
you're making the money
you save the money for when you can't
make the money for whatever reason you
can't make that money anymore
because usually that kind of large yes
doesn't last forever you know
um so the the secret is hold on to it
live modestly or what was the line um
bart scott told me
um that steve beshear taught him he said
you can live like a king for a day
or live like a prince forever so if you
can
find a comfortable lifestyle that you
can maintain with the money you're
generating
during your peak you know revenue
generating years and you can be set for
life
if you start you know balling and
spending like a baller
you know you're gonna you're gonna find
a way even with 50 million dollars or
200 million dollars
you'll find a way to live paycheck to
paycheck right
get yourself in debt as a lot of these
guys do and with a lot of these slimy
money managers and finance people that
exist out here that just make a living
off of ripping off athletes that are
making a lot of money too it just makes
it 10 times harder
but but enough about florida even
parents yeah
yeah no no everybody listen
nobody knows how much money you and i
make it doesn't get published in the
[ __ ] newspaper
these guys their salaries are online
i mean the sports pages are filled with
you know
just as many dollar signs as they are
statistics you know like you know
like people are interested in that can
you imagine if you work in an office if
anybody works in an office anymore
where everybody knows how much money
everybody else is making how
tense that would be that's what that's
what sports
is like it's it's it's intense and so
what does that do
that puts a target on your back from
everybody
on the outside and everybody's there uh
with their hand out or to take advantage
of you i know
a a guy who is a um so the nfl pa
um the players association the union has
a list of what they call like
certified financial advisors and really
all that means is you gave the union
like
two grand they did a background cursory
background check on you
and they put your excuse me your name on
their on their website
problem is the players who go there
looking for financial advisors think
that
these guys are somehow approved you know
by the union
that's not the case so i know a guy who
went to
a a mix or a cocktail hour
in a city not not in florida but uh it
was i think was in texas and
he it was a mixer for
nflpa certified financial advisors kind
of meet greet trade notes talk about
clients
he said every single person
almost to a man and woman in that
cocktail
hour all they were talking about is how
dumb their clients are
and how to take advantage of them okay
and he said
i left that room i took my name off the
l
off the website because i and i never
looked at it guys i never wanted to be
associated
with any of those people again they were
basically he felt like just a room full
of predators
uh uh you know trying to take advantage
of these guys here's the thing about
athletes
there is a misconception that they are
stupid they are not stupid
they are smart about what they're smart
about like all of us right
we know what we know and we we maybe if
we're lucky we know what we don't know
but many of us don't know what we don't
know
and that's the problem listen you go try
to learn a playbook
in the nfl and then go execute that in
3d
while a bunch of guys are coming at you
trying to murder you all right like
either you have to have a little bit of
smarts to figure that out
they don't know financial they're not
financially literate that's not their
fault most americans out of college
aren't financially literate and let's be
real when these guys are in college
no one is telling them that their
priority needs to be on financial
literacy
they're saying you know you know take
underwater basket weaving and go learn
the playbook is what their
you know is what their priorities are so
you know and they're telling them
they're good at this one thing and they
focus on that one thing but and that
becomes a problem
when they discover that they have to pay
their taxes which they you know they
don't know anything about and and it's
you know i think that's why broke as a
34 30 really hit the zeitgeist at that
moment you had lebron
and d wade and michael vick and magic
johnson tweeting like everybody needs to
turn this on
right now because it was i think the old
to this day the only 30
30 that was like a call to action where
you could say
oh [ __ ] this is a real problem happening
every day
and the most heartening thing about it
was obviously it's cool to have lebron
tweeting about your movie
but even cooler well that's pretty dope
athletes
who were tweeting about it because they
were like my favorite tweets like i'm
not gonna be in broke part two
like they took pride in like smart is
the new stupid as far as spending money
was concerned you know like i don't need
to go buy a 5 000
suit i'ma put that away for my kids for
college you know or you know
so i and i think that that was that was
the not to say that people aren't still
going broke but i think a lot of it was
like a scared straight thing
you know it was like a lot of people
woke up to the reality that this isn't
going to last forever and then you just
set themselves up for their futures
i